في موقع التدريب عسكري في مقاطعه ساري
جنوب شرق انجلترا يختبر اطفائيون شاحنه
للطرق الوعره مصممه للتاكد من قدرتهم على
التعامل مع مستقبل ينتظر ان تكفر فيه
الحرائق لتصبح امرا معتادا وطبيعيا
في الاعوام الخمسه والعشرين الماضيه التي
شاركت فيها في اخماد حرائق الغابات اعتدنا
ان تحدث هذه الحرائق كل عشره اعوام لكن مع
التغيرات البيئيه ودرجات حراره الارض
بدانا نشهد حدوث حرائق الغابات في المملكه
المتحده وخصوصا في الجنوب الشرقي كل عام
تقريبا
في الصيف الماضي عندما سجلت بريطانيا
حالات جفاف واعلى درجه حراره على الاطلاق
شهدت موجه من حرائق الغابات في ساري وكانت
الاكبر في تاريخ البلاد الحديث حيث امتدت
الى مسافه تزيد على عشره كيلومترات ومع
ذلك فان ساري ليست فريده من نوعها داخل
بريطانيا حيث تندلع حرائق الغابات بشكل
متزايد في جميع انحاء البلاد على الرغم من
سمعتها بالطقس الرطب والمتقلب والمروج
الخضراء
لدينا جزيره مكتظه بالسكان وتفاعل حقيقي
بين البيئه الطبيعيه والناس وعندما يحدث
ذلك فان احتمال الحرائق يكون موجودا دائما
نبه مكسب الارصاد الجويه البريطاني في
دراسه جديده الى ان الحراره الشديده التي
شهدتها البلاد العام الماضي ستصبح اكثر
تكرارا وشده بسبب تغير المناخ ومعها يشتد
خطر الحرائق
المتزايده في كثير من الاماكن
[تصفيق]
يرش الاطفائيون الاراضي البورى المحيطه
بالمياه اثناء تدريبهم على معالجه عدو
مختلف تغير المناخ واستثمرت خدمه الاطفاء
والانقاذ في مقاطعه ساري نحو مليونين
دولار في موارد الوقايه من حرائق الغابات
ومكافحتها يشمل ذلك اربع مركبات لمكافحه
الحرائق من طراز يونيموك قادره على رش الف
وخمسمائه لتر من الماء في الدقيقه
لمسافه تصل الى 60 مترا باستخدام خرطوم
مثبت
اضافه الى عشرين شاحنه من طراز لاند روفر
مجهزه لمكافحه الحرائق يمتلك عناصر
الاطفاء ايضا سترات ونظارات وخوذه جديده
خفيفه الوزن مصممه خاصه لمواجهه خطر حرائق
الغابات الذي يت زايد مع جفاف المناخ في
بريطانيا وعدم بالقدره على التنبؤ به